Steve Mariucci is on the phone right now
my compadre from NFL gameday morning how
are you mooch I'm good what a weekend we
had a football on rich it was no it was
unbelievable what's the biggest shootout
you've ever been a part of Steve like
like that like that game we saw in it
well yes okay as a coach when I was at
Cal we went 56 to 55 against Arizona
with four overtimes you can thank me for
changing the college overtime rule
because we went four overtimes in Cal
Stadium and we finally won the game
hands are on the field it was awesome
but the official said had you not wanted
there we were going to cancel the game
and postpone it to the next day or the
next week because it was getting dark we
had no lights so because of that they
may change the rule and said okay you're
gonna kick your be able to kick in
overtime twice but then you have to go
for two because we can't have 14
different over times in in stadiums that
have no lights to get into that
situation again so we 56 55 so you were
part of the game that that changed
College overtime we have a go / - yes
guys can you imagine they say okay we
can't play anymore it's too dark come
back tomorrow what absolutely so what
about what about pros the biggest
shootout in the pros that you're part of
like like what we saw in Atlanta I'm
trying to think I don't I don't I don't
remember anything quite like that I'm
drawing a blank right now rich alright
no let me go on this one the Sunday
night game last night
did Matt Patricia see when you were part
of the Lions sideline and you threw a
challenge flag and you said it was a
little an angry flag very fired up flag
did you see him throw that challenge
flag last night that went like 50 yards
and something like football Steve did
you see that we are there you got it you
got to be angry you got what a win for
him right yeah just a couple of weeks we
were talking about a weeks ago how
everybody's upset at him in Detroit
because he practiced too hard and
training camp and this is not going to
be a happy marriage that win against his
mentor Bill Belichick was a huge for the
Lions and Matt Patricia he was fired up
yeah I know and and you could see the
way that the the players were all
excited for him to
yeah maybe they look good well you know
what Patriots didn't look good so what
do you make of it Steve what I make of
it is is what we're seeing in the NFL
right now is some teams that should be
good we'll have that Mulligan kind of
game okay and some teams that should be
bad you know like the bills were ranked
32nd in the Power Rankings are good
enough to go into Minnesota and just put
a beat-down on them it's unbelievable
you never on any given Sunday you just
never know what to expect you're gonna
have good teams flop and bad teams play
well and that's what makes this this
league so interesting and the Patriots
right now you know I you know I'm
watching them you know because I
mentioned this on the air a couple weeks
ago they're trying to get their 16th two
season in a row of double-digit wins
right 16th in a row to tie the 49ers yes
thank you very much
and you know what they may not get it
rich I know I think though that when
Edelman comes back that that's got a no
big difference maker and Josh Gordon
yeah I'll see if I'll believe it when I
see Gordon on that field and he's gonna
look in that offense Steve Mariucci here
on the Rich Eisen show so let's get into
the Clay Matthews roughing the passer
penalty Steve you were on the player
advisory board the players Safety
Advisory Board now this this is not
something that you guys discussed that
the EM pre-emphasis on this now 23 year
old rule did not come from your advisory
board what comes from our advisory board
is we study the injuries the data the
frequency and those sort of things of
all injuries concussions or knees ever
you name it and and what happens is
because of the data when we find out on
kickoff returns the most dangerous play
we make adjustments to that particular
play you saw we created more touch backs
that makes it less injuries as simple as
that
you remembered Richie look at the big
picture it's all about keeping the
players healthier all right
roll back time a few years remember when
Carson Palmer blew his knee out and he
was done when he was playing for the
Susan
remember when Tom Brady blew his knee
out in the pocket and he missed the
whole season well when those things
happen sometimes you say alright we
can't have people hitting the
quarterbacks in the knees so we changed
the rule remember I know I know and that
led to some crazy roughing the passer
penalties where somebody's crawling and
hit somebody in a shin and then a flag
comes down and thankfully we don't see
that anymore so the question is is I
understand why the rules are put into
place but is it possible that because
the NFL
likes what we're talking about because
they double down on it last week well I
know they did but the reason this rule
has been changed is because of Aaron
Rodgers getting hit by Anthony Barr and
driven to the turf and he's out for the
season with a shoulder so so that that
that prompted the discussion okay how do
we further protect the quarterback in
and out of the pocket well it came to
this I mean it's we're the kind of a
think-tank all right we don't make rules
we kind of suggest and we we say why
this play is dangerous or this kind of
hit is dangerous then there's a Rules
Committee then the owners have to vote
but anyway so it was like all right
we're not going to we're going to try to
eliminate what two hits on the
quarterback one the big guy hitting them
in the chops and then the second one the
ground with all that extra weight and
you know what we're we're learning what
we're learning because there are
intended unintended consequences that
it's hard to play the game that way Clay
Matthews is actually trying to go by the
rules and he's still getting called
three weeks in a row and and it's hard
to officiate very hard to officiate so I
think there will be more discussion on
all right how can we better this rule
our intentions are good but boy is it
difficult when things happen so fast
like this right because William Hayes
now blew out his knee yesterday yeah
that's it moving his body all weight off
of Derek Carr in the process and now
what we're doing is we're making guys
think as opposed to being instinctive
and that anybody who tells me
anybody who I've interviewed over the
last 15 years with NFL Network and with
this show Steve as you will you
be able to attest having played the game
yourself and coached it for as long as
you have any time that somebody says
when you're out there not being
instinctive and you're thinking or maybe
you're thinking about an injury or
you're thinking about a penalty that is
that's when things get dangerous that's
when people actually do get hurt yeah
yeah they get hurt when there's no rules
to so I think you know here's what's
happening with quarterbacks okay they're
an endangered species we're trying to
protect what we're trying to do is keep
their hits and with off the knees right
off the knees and off the shoulder neck
and head those are the areas that when
quarterbacks get hurt they're out
they're gone the team goes in the tank
and so does the fan base and everything
else and so the midsection hit him in
the midsection they have a flak jacket
on if you get a bruised rib that so be
it but it's then it's the shoulders neck
and head we're trying to stay off of and
the knees now we have to rethink this
thing and talk about it because it's
very difficult very difficult to
officiate and play because when you
watch that last one with Clay Matthews
and God bless him he's very Rodgers best
friend he that nobody was more teed off
at Anthony bargain than Clay Matthews
last year for for wrecking his
quarterback self but he tried to keep
his head out of there he didn't hit him
in the neck or the head he went to the
side he I mean he's trying to brace
himself a little bit with his legs and
his arms he's doing the best he can yet
his body still comes down on Alex Smith
yeah so it's just a bugger right now
we're gonna have to talk about this it's
not going to change I don't think it's
going to change risk during the season I
think I think he'll play you know the
other thing is this this initiating the
contact with the helmet I think the
players are doing a better job well also
to Steve Mariucci NFL Network my
compadre from NFL gameday morning here
on the show also but they started
calling it differently they started
removing from from their repertoire that
we saw throughout the preseason just the
mere fact of a defensive player standing
in front of an offensive player and both
guys bracing for contact yeah heads
actually hit parts of bodies and here
comes if like that's been removed so
yeah that's why I'm saying that whatever
they
the preseason you know because they when
when the new rule happens officials call
it like crazy in the preseason just for
learning purposes for everybody right
players fans officials right and then
they kind of went back and said okay
what's incidental contact well a lot of
it is incidental you don't have to call
it every time somebody scrapes helmets
and and when things happen quickly you
know so I think that's been cleaned up a
little bit so that does this body on all
of your weight on a quarterback that's
got to get cleaned up a little bit well
let me talk about protecting young
quarterbacks here by by not starting
them despite you trading up to get him
or you you definitely using a
first-round selection on him now Josh
Rosen comes into his first game action
yesterday and what a situation in which
to put him I mean Baker Mayfield came in
into a 2-minute situation and got
comfortable fast as we all saw to the
kickoff of week 3 on NFL Network with
the Browns but that was at the end of
the first half now it's like Steve
Wilkes pushed the Josh Rosen button with
mere minutes to go in a game and Khalil
Mack breathing down the rookies neck in
a clear passing situation okay walk me
through what coach's mindset if you can
Steve hey not all Steve's think alike I
don't know what Steve Wilk was thinking
about you know he just maybe he wanted a
spark maybe he's just hoping that this
is a Baker Mayfield moment maybe he had
enough with Sam Bradford I don't know
that's always a big decision rich when
to play the young quarterback alright in
Sam Donald's case that's different than
you know because you got an old guy that
was Josh McCown and let's let's get to
you know let's get to this and he's
gonna be our starter playing day one but
all the other guys whether it's Josh
Allen who played a nice game right Baker
Mayfield played a nice game here comes
Josh Rosen in a tough situation against
a tough defense and you know had he had
he made some first downs I put it in the
end zone coach looks smart looks good
like hey perfect timing way to go if it
flops then you say well I got to make
another decision who do I start next
week but eventually all these guys will
start it's a matter of win and you got
to be a little
loyal to the Sam Bradford's or the Tyrod
Taylor's for a little bit because you
brought them in there for a reason with
the with their intention of being a
player for you and then you know it's
Rosen's gonna be around there for a long
time you didn't need to start day one no
and I don't think the way that it went
down is gonna shake his confidence at
all
I mean I don't think so a confident kid
but it's very interesting What did he
say for next week what's gonna happen
next they guess what's the I think he's
got a look at the film you know he's got
a look at the film I know I don't talk
about this right now I got to decide
later
did you ever Steve from a podium use the
I've gotta look at the film as getting
out of saying something from the podium
and that moment did you ever use one you
definitely didn't need to look at the
film did you ever use that probably
probably because I probably did because
I had Steve Young with with a concussion
you know and this and that and there was
he can cost less you know and so you say
that to buy yourself some time to talk
it over with your staff yes to look at
the film talk it over with your GM which
way you want to go because if you start
answering questions in the heat of the
moment on a press conference after a big
win or a big loss you might regret it so
it just buys you some time to hey I want
to sit down and think through this thing
and we can talk tomorrow
coaches have a press conference every
single day every day driver used to
drive me nuts but it's sometimes it's
better to push it off to tomorrow let me
think about this sleep on it and I'll
meet with my staff after we see the tell
ya it's Mayfield by the way Hugh Jackson
announced that about half an hour ago
its Mayfield that's a shocker isn't it
it's gonna be interesting to see what
Steve Wilkes does you know I think well
I mean the minute that you take Sam
Bradford out in a situation like that I
mean talk about a vote of no-confidence
it's you just put the kid in their their
own three the Seahawks are coming to
town let's see if they can get a spark
from ya quarters one last you mentioned
a spark that's important rich because
sometimes changing it up you know
putting in your relief or whatever that
is it sometimes it does give you a spark
sometimes it doesn't sometimes it does
but I think that's what Steve Wolfe was
kind of open for he saw happen with
Baker Mayfield that was like a miracle I
mean it was unbelievable
watch Baker Mayfield win that game in
Cleveland so that's what you're looking
for not one by the way I think you've
given this show a spark Steve by calling
it you know that's I think the show is
doing very well before you called him
but I think he gave before I let you go
Steve what do you think happens tonight
if it's magic V stealers who are in
desperate need of a win what do you
think happens Monday night what's going
on over there I mean you know it's I'm
anxious to see just what kind of team
shows up because they seem to have a lot
of things going on and then fits magic
you know he crashed my party and I let
him in thinking he's going to be in the
playoffs right and so I think NFL fans
in general love seeing the underdog
succeed at times like the Browns or like
the Tampa Bay Bucs likes it who's just
been he's got nine lives but this one
seems to be his best life and so I kind
of kind of rootin for the Bucs and fit
to see if you can pull off another
miracle who did you choose who did you
pick in the Picts contest who did you
take I'll tell you who I took we're
going again we're going against each
other I took the Bucs to go through you
know I think they win tonight they might
they might mooch you take care all right
you're gonna see a Thursday Steve
Mariucci you know Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience